there is an item on a body on a bench
on a balcony behind a locked door behind
an illusory wall behind some boxes in an
alleyway
in the third level of boletaria castle
and none of this
was in the original game and after a
solid week of theorizing
testing and searching we finally found
the key to the door
if it wasn't for this online culture
that games have now
i don't think this would have ever been
put in the game and you know if it
wasn't for the cult following this game
has
i don't think anyone would have ever
found it i'll reveal what's behind the
door towards the end of this video
it's fitting to delay your gratification
a little bit for the sake of this story
on the 14th of november just a few days
after the release of demon souls
a user posted a video to reddit does
anyone know how to open this door in 1-3
it's new people went wild what if this
door leads us to the sixth archestone
dlc
wait maybe it connects to the closed
door in bloodborne
no don't be stupid it's clearly hiding
elden rings gameplay trailer
at this stage there were just infinite
possibilities until
it was discovered that you could use
photo mode in an adjacent laneway
to peek over the balcony revealing an
item
and luckily one of the five people who
owned a playstation 5
was distortion 2 one of my favorite
speedrunners and
a big fat cheater there's a glitch that
exists where you can walk up into walls
as they load into the game and he abused
this to navigate a path towards the item
but bluepoint were one step ahead they
had anticipated players glitching
through the map to get there
and they placed this invisible box
around the area as this extra layer of
protection for something like this
distortion if you're listening you
cheated not only the game
but yourself with bluepoint taunting us
the search continued
they'd put things like this in their
remakes before in shadow of the colossus
there was a secret door that required 79
coins to open
and something myself and many others
came up with was to try and farm
79 gold coins from the fat officials to
see if that did anything
some poor soul on reddit actually tried
this to no avail
and theories kept flying what if it has
something to do with the weird goat
faces hidden in the credit screens
actually why is there a small chest here
that's illuminated so curiously
wait what if it has to do with all of
those weird audio glitches that some
players have reported
do the items on the steps in front of
the door matter
are they a clue is that a face in the
bag can the solution only be seen with a
certain filter on
what about fracture mode what about
fractured mode
finally a player named maledictus nix
playing in fraction mode which flips the
game horizontally
in pure white world tendency found a new
item
in the same stage as the locked door it
was hit another ladder
in a featureless dead end under a box a
ceramic
coin made of dried clay extremely
brittle and fragile the glimmer has
faded much like its value
it's also a consumable item that
recovers a tiny amount of hp
so coins were back on the menu but don't
consume them for the health bonus for
the love of god
instead find more coins
people quickly speculated that these
would only be discoverable
in fraction mode and in pure white
tendencies hidden within breakable
rubble
and they were right we had an actual
goal now and
filled with new determination players
began discovering coins left and right
four more were found in pure white world
tendency in 1-3
in a featureless room off to the side of
a courtyard in 2-2
on an island down the lava river in 3-1
pass the human ball in one of those
small locked cells
under a chair in 4-1 within the grave
robbers cell
and then five more in pure black world
tendencies so
in 1-2 up the stairs before the tower
night
under a table by the winch in 2-1
past the three dogs that are at the
bottom of this ramp tucked away in this
dead end lane
within some boxes in 3-1 on the right as
you approach the fool's idol
back and before a fence in 4-2 hidden
within the pit that patches kicks you
down and finally
in 5-2 before you fight the dirty
colossus
up a ramp in a room in a box so that
made 10 coins
which was a really neat even number and
it even matched what looked to be the
number 10
on the back of the coin and when you
traded them with sparkly the crow
she would react positively
but then she would just drop the items
right back at you
maybe we didn't have enough at this
point it had been a long time
since the last discovery and people had
been searching endlessly
how many more coins could there even be
desperate now
some players tried duping the coins by
trading them to other players and then
rolling back their saves so that they
would still have their coins
but blue point had thought of that too
when picked up by other players
they become broken coins they are
ceramic after all
and they're very fragile so when you
drop them they break
it's such a good thing that bluepoint
puts so much effort into making sure
that players can't cheat
back at it then so far there did seem to
be a pattern
coins could only be found at each end of
world's tendency
and there were two coins per world
except
for in the fifth world the valley of
defilement
here we had only found one coin hidden
in black world tendency
so for hours and hours players
scoured every inch of that goddamn swamp
until
finally it was found by none other than
shrek himself
but it was a lie notorious dark souls
deviant metal fruit had found a coin
elsewhere and then dropped it and picked
it up again
in the middle of the swamp just to throw
players off the scent
many were not fooled by him and his
accomplice but
for the truly desperate precious time
was wasted
enthusiasm waning the search continued
until hours later
the 11th coin was found but it wasn't
found in the swamp
no instead it was found in the first
level of boletaria castle
in that room from which two soldiers
burst after you rescue a strava
this was the third coin found in
boletaria so it
shattered the theory that each world
only had two coins
and the swamp was gratefully abandoned
as people filtered back into other
worlds
while others searched distortion 2 that
big cheater we mentioned earlier
he had a different idea what if he was
to go into
new game plus and collect more coins
there
every new game plus cycle would net him
11 more coins and
on new game plus plus distortion traded
30 coins with sparkly the crow
and it worked he received a key covered
in red rust
the mystery of the door was solved
at this point i set out on my own
journey to find all these coins
i wanted to get footage of my own for
you guys and i wanted to see what it was
like
going through three new game cycles just
to collect them all
it wasn't fun i will say though while
gold coins ended up being unrelated to
the door
they're still kind of related using them
glitches your luck stat
at the maiden in black and with the blue
blood sword
i mean you do decent damage wait am i
cheated too even with this slightly
overpowered weapon
a lot of things will still kill you in
one hit and it should still take you
like 12 hours to go through this many
new game plus cycles
but luckily while i went through all of
this i had audible to keep me sane
consider visiting audible.com or text
varti video to 500 500
to start your free one month trial so
you beat all the bosses you
make sure you always get rid of human
form in the nexus to make sure
that you hit pure white world tendency
in all worlds
and then you get all the white world
tendency coins then you farm stones of
ephemeral eyes
then you die in human form in each world
until you get them to black world
tendency
you get all the black tendency coins
then you go into new game plus
and you do it again you kill all the
bosses you kill yourself in the nexus
each time you get permanently stuck in a
wall
on the way to old monk you go to wait
what i can't warp out of here
i can use items but i can't use the warp
item and
yep i'm being invaded by players who are
becoming the old monk
so i can't even get someone to kill me
here and the cutscene is unskippable too
oh [ __ ] this is how it ends hours of
tedious grinding
an entire character ruined stuck in a
wall
for all eternity i'm not doing that
again
unless holy [ __ ] it actually worked
you can just walk out from the menu
thank god
so finally i get the key i open the door
i walk inside
and there it is so i started to take
some photos of my character looting the
item you know i wanted to make sure i
could get a good thumbnail for this
video
looks good right that's a great shot
photo mode is actually so good
anyway here i'm thinking okay i'm going
to log out
and i want to keep the item there
because i'm going to come back later and
take some more photos you know i'm not
100 convinced that i have a good
thumbnail photo yet
so i log out but i should probably check
if it's still there and it's gone i'm
probably the only [ __ ] person who
could come up with a reason to log out
right in front of the item
but yeah it's the rarest item in the
game because
the percentage of players who will
actually go through the difficulty of
three new game cycles just to get this
thing
is going to be very low and you know
even when you do like me
there's no guarantee that it will wait
there for you i love blue point for this
remake but
god damn man i don't know if i'm gonna
have the dedication to make an entirely
new character to go through all of this
again
anyway later guys unless
hear me out what if i take the rusted
key
into yet another new game plus cycle
it's actually very likely that the item
would respawn but
what's unlikely is that the key would
actually make it through to new game
plus because no other keys and demon
souls actually act this way
and you know i would have to kill every
boss again
so is it even worth it but i eventually
decide that you know it is worth a shot
and
oh my god the key is still there so i
quickly go through the game to get to
the door
i kill an archdemon i fight my way to
the tower knight fog
i get to the door i unlock it i walk
inside
and
[Music]
the penetrator's armor set a reward for
surpassing impossible odds
the intricate design of this helmet was
uniquely crafted for the penetrator
one of the boletarian heroes excellent
for fending against
piercing attacks which man that extra
defense is so useful
in new game plus 3 let me tell you jokes
aside
this is a good reward penetrator has a
very signature armor set
actually to the point where in the
original game players always wondered
why this wasn't an item that you could
get
so to add it back here and to come up
with this whole challenge
is thoughtful it's meaningful and i also
just love that bluepoint incentivized
breaking the rubble in souls games for
once
as a zelda fan that's something i always
thought this games could do more of
so blue point well played
but you know what it's actually possible
that we haven't found all of the ceramic
coins yet
people kind of stopped searching as soon
as the armor was discovered but we
figured out
you actually need 26 coins to get the
key
and we currently have 11. so if we get
two more coins that makes 13 per new
game plus cycle
meaning you could get the armor in new
game plus not
new game plus plus which would actually
be so
much faster than what you have to go
through now
so listen if you can find a playstation
5 in the real world
how hard could it be to find these last
two coins right
so if you have a playstation 5 get out
there and try to claim one in your name
there might be more but congratulations
to everyone with a ps5 that joined the
hunt
and congratulations to those without it
too honestly because a lot of you guys
contributed your theories
and your ideas i wanted to make this
video to mark
an interesting point in seoul's history
and i wanted to help
everyone who didn't know about this feel
a little bit of what it was like at the
time
so thank you for watching and thank you
to audible honestly who kept me sane
with this sponsorship while i spent 12
hours hunting for coins
while i did this i listened to one of my
favorite fantasy books
it's called sword in the storm and it's
an audio book that you can listen to for
free
during your 30-day audible trial while
you listen to this sample
go and visit
text vati audible.com to 500 500 to
start your free trial
here's an excerpt from the first chapter
come and join us conovar
let us talk of a new piece
demon blade stood silently for a moment
his strong hands resting on the pommel
of his sword
his patchwork cloak billowing in the
breeze
you have not asked me here to talk
he said his voice deep and powerful
you have asked me here to die
come then traitors
i am here and i am
alone slowly
they drew their swords i could feel
their fear then
as the sun fell in crimson fire
they attacked i think it's really
important for a healthy mind to listen
to one audiobook a month
and being an audible subscriber gives
you one free audiobook
credit every month so it kind of works
out perfectly
if you're especially keen you might also
be interested in audible plus which
grants you unlimited access to thousands
of select originals
audiobooks and podcasts at 4.95 a month
for the first
six months this is actually a special
offer available only for a limited time
but i'm always happy to take on audible
as a sponsor because
this is actually a service that i do use
in my daily life and
i'm excited to just talk about my
favorite stories with you all
but thank you guys for watching
subscribe and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you